on
air all right guys am I live put a one
in the chat if you can hear me I'm going
live on Rumble to
now what do I do go live
okay one in the chat if you can hear
me um on Rumble we're going oh I see
ones in the chat all right let me let me
say hi to the people hello Arizona hello
red
pill
chy ice hi
[Music]
um stranger things Fred all right good
all right let's see is Rumble
going so it says it says we're live on
Rumble oh I click here what do you mean
the to oh that is not what I
wanted oh okay but I I should turn off
the sound I'm
guessing
Okay um is it on sorry guys guys this is
going to be a little bit of a struggle
stream today um the reason it's a
struggle stream is because we're now
live on Facebook Rumble we're trying to
we're trying to expand the brand for you
guys
okay um so give me give me one second
while we try to fix this see if it's
going on Rumble but you know to start
guys how's your day going how's it how's
your your time oh holy live on R
Rumble okay I think we're on put a one
in the chat on Rumble if I'm
live one in the chat on Rumble South
Africa we got South Africa in
here okay so what are we talking about
today what did I make the is it going or
no
a okay all right blessing's gonna try to
fix
this how is you guys' weekends you know
couple updates on the
channel um I went to the us this weekend
I did um the Hodge twins podcast so that
was a lot of fun that'll be out in like
three weeks I think that podcast is
gonna get me in trouble I won't lie to
you guys
they I'll just say this they have a lot
of pent up anger about a certain type of
woman and
it's gonna get me in trouble I feel it
but whatever whatever whatever
whatever I also did um what is that Alex
Stein's
show that one oh I'm on Rumble now it
says no audio all right one in the chat
on Rumble if you can hear me um Alex
Stein's show was a lot of fun I I wasn't
really expecting them to bring on men to
hit on me I I didn't really know what to
do a lot of comments said Pearl you look
so awkward well it's cuz I felt awkward
you know imagine you're going into a
professional setting and they just bring
in men to to you know you're just like I
don't know about this I don't know okay
I think it's working on Rumble I I I'm
sorry if it's
not but I want to talk about my soul
searching I've been doing maybe not soul
searching because I forget women say
that when they're like going crazy but I
I've had a bit of an evolution in the
way that I think
currently and I think this
um I'm GNA start
over all right let's pretend this is the
beginning of the live stream okay so
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube Channel please please
please like the video please hit a like
you know that's the most important
metric that YouTube uses to push out
these streams so I can see your comments
on both sides I see Sigma m to and
Rumble and I do see Todd's or no Todd on
the bottom of the chat in YouTube so I
do see your comments I'm G to be looking
at these chats um but likes they're
free and you know it helps push out
these streams if you guys can please
send a cash app or a venmo um we're
setting up Bitcoin to receive that too
as you guys know we are demonetized so
you guys um really help me do what I do
what's what's wrong now oh don't don't
worry okay he he's fixing that all right
so no we're still demonetized on
February 12th we get to reapply so you
know we're going to
reapply and pray that's all I can really
do right guys pray pray
pray um but I'm actually kind of glad I
got
demonetized and the reason I'm glad is
because I I was just I was working so
hard before I got got
demonetized it it was I can hear myself
now blessing could you do it I can hear
it through the door and oh it says audio
is low on
Rumble says audio is
low
um is he coming back I hope he's coming
back I feel like I'm trying to I'm
trying to go for this
but okay would I turn it up here maybe
all right tell me if that's
better oh thank you a $ five Super Chat
on Rumble thank you thank you guys okay
so oh and I'm gonna watch my phone I'm
gonna turn off my do not disturb so if I
see a venmo notification I'm gonna read
it they're still complaining about the
Audio I don't know
what's
okay
well it's good
now okay okay I'm gonna start over my
story I'm really sorry guys I'm sorry
we're gonna we're gonna improve and get
better you know
so taking this time off has allowed me
to do a couple things one and you guys
already know on this channel is spend a
lot of time with my father and my
dad it's so interesting talking to
people in their 50s and above because
they really saw like most of their life
they didn't have social media so you see
that their worldview just isn't as
polluted by
it um so my I've gotten to spend a lot
of time with my dad some old friends and
it's just been really really nice I was
working so hard before I got demonetized
and I just it was too much and now I
took a little break I'm a little happier
you know um my dad doesn't like media he
doesn't really he's been on the channel
once or twice but you guys are quite
rude a lot to my family so I don't put
them in a ton of stuff maybe here and
there but then people think it's okay
even tradcon men think it's okay to
insult them so it's just you know
whatever but says audio is still low are
you guys playing with me I don't know
what to do Rumble I this is this is this
is why I do I do one stream it's kind of
whatever okay
so back to what I was talking
about so the past couple of weeks
there's been an argument between the
tradcons and the red pillar now what is
red pill I don't think red pill is what
most people think it is I don't even
know if I would be considered red pill I
talk about a lot of red pill stuff I
tend to agree with their point of view
but red pill is really just guys coming
together trying to solve their problems
and you know looking at the way that
women
are and figuring out how to navigate the
modern landscape so for example we have
myON now myON gives the
prescription that you should sleep with
50 women before you settle down now I
don't think I'm in the position to give
men advice on how to date court and
sleep with women that's not my expertise
I don't I've never done that that's just
not me okay
[Applause]
so the reason myON says this is because
women like men with experience
not your Christian women are not any
different and or special okay this is a
common misconception that there's
special women women are still women
women tend to like men with experience
that's why myON says stuff like that
okay
um
okay so the last couple
weeks I've really been thinking about
the way the world is
going and I've been thinking about
how I've noticed in the last five years
I have seen more and more sex
workers I have seen more and more
divorces I have seen more and more
wokeism in the
churches I have only seen wokeness
getting more woke in my lifetime I've
seen marriage really virtually disappear
as an
institution I mean in my life most
people I know that got married were
dating for maybe five years and then
decided to get married really gone are
the days and and typically what I
see when you know in the church they
might do it a little more
traditionally and you know I always get
this criticism Pearl it's like they
become like the god police how often do
you go to
church I go to church I mean I skip
sometimes but I go as much as I as much
as I can all right I'm I'm a Catholic
all right but I even in the Catholic
church and I've been in
non-denominational churches
I've even like been to um Pentecostal
churches this year I still see single
mothers I still see older single women
you know even the church isn't immune to
the culture because people are people
and women are women and that's a lesson
that I learned from my dad my dad always
hated motivational speakers he always
always always hated
preachers and I didn't understand why a
lot of the stuff they said I thought it
was true I thought dad you
know why like why are you so bothered
he's like look at they're just full of
none of them have a real
plan and you know I'm a woman so I never
really had a problem with them okay but
then I got older and I started to
understand what he was talking about and
all these pastors they would come out
with like having side chicks or
embezzlement and it would be back to
what my dad originally said which is
people are
people so another thing my dad and I
disagree on is my dad um he is
pro not pro-choice but he's not really
too bothered about abortion now me I've
seen an abortion I think it is a
terrible terrible thing I think it is
evil I think it is one of the one of the
most evil things you can do as a
woman
but the way my dad sees it my dad is a
really really practical guy
my Dad ran
um he ran a company with over 200 like
like roughly 200
employees
and he doesn't really care too much
about
what sounds good he cares about what
works he's just one of those guys and
what I I increasingly understood I don't
know I guess the older I got and The
more I've been in media is that
everyone's just trying to sound good
instead of do
good you know like even the abortion
debate and I realized even me okay let's
use me as an example when I was talking
about women not voting it's like funny I
mean I believe it in my my
soul but I I don't know if I see women
not being able to vote
ever coming in my lifetime how would we
go from arguing what a woman
is to actually repealing the
19th you
know oh the the blessing the volume's
low on
Rumble that's what they're
saying okay
um and even and it was interesting
because I started to notice patterns not
about what's moral but what about what I
started to notice
patterns not necessarily patterns about
what's moral but what
works and I noticed that even the people
you know like let's use Tate as an
example they're they're saying that
volume's low on
Rumble oh it's their software
okay well people on Rumble tell Rumble
the software is not are you sure it's
the
software
okay I know this is why I'm not the
biggest fan of the Dual streams because
there just always seems to be issues but
it's okay okay um oh I think he they
said it's better
now
okay okay what was I talking
about what was I talking about
oh and so back to the abortion thing so
you know I could say all day abortion is
wrong here's why it's wrong and explain
why it's wrong but people are people and
women are going to keep getting
abortions and it doesn't really matter
what I
say it's legal and it doesn't really
seem like it's going away anytime
soon and you almost start to like look
at the world in a different way like
instead
of we all think that we can change the
world and to be honest the world kind of
is how it is and it it's so funny
because these content creators get like
they
almost they almost they become super
grandiose and like start to they they
almost want to play God and I see this a
lot with that chase guy where he feels
like it's his job to save the west and
go on these podcasts and talk and the
problem is none of it's like actionable
advice like is vote is women voting
going anywhere
no is any of this degeneracy really
going to stop are we going to see
women being less of
I I don't think so I think you're going
to see more sex workers in 10 years than
now I think it's going to be more normal
for you know I'm seeing sex workers run
for Congress I think it's going to be
more normal and this
isn't this isn't really what I want or
what I would like to happen but I just
start to think about it more and more
and I
think I don't really
see you know any most content creators
having a real like plan of
action and I'm not I'm not trying to
diss them because I'm not even saying
I'm better you know I'm just saying the
more I think about it like abortion
let's get rid of abortion
how with the six female Supreme Court or
whatever it is the majority female
Supreme Court
Justices you
think that abortion is going
somewhere
okay so and I see the chat they say God
and then I'll I'll also see men oh Tate
was who I was thinking of this is no no
insult to him at all but I'll also see
men prescribing things they didn't do
men tend to need to sleep around a bit
for women to want them but I'll see them
come on the other side of that and then
say that it's all degeneracy and and
evil even though that that system got
them to where they are with
women and I'll look at the results of
waiting till marriage that like tradcon
kind of push and what I see is is women
kind of marrying dorky guys they don't
really like like
um and this isn't me you know trying to
be mean but I I I don't meet many
conservative tra men that that are
different and what they'll do is they'll
come out and tell
everybody you
know you
know go like there's there's um a
certain couple that I see and I I don't
even mean this to be mean but I'm just
being like objective facts here they'll
say hey we're doing it the right way we
waited till marriage and I look at the
couple and it's an older woman a younger
guy and the woman has Nudes on the
internet and I think well if that's what
you guys are
selling it doesn't really seem to be
like what guys are going to buy
by
so this is kind of just a new train of
thought I've had recently and I just
wanted to talk about it I'm not claiming
to have all the answers I certainly
don't but I you start to realize that a
lot of like media is just a
show and really when I started like I
didn't it's like you're just looking for
what's true and you realize that
everyone's kind of talking to an
audience everyone's trying to build a
brand and it's just like a show like
everyone's they they don't actually
think anything's going to change they
don't have a real plan to change it's
just a show let's see who can look
better in a
debate we are brain yeah we could
brainstorm I'm not but okay so now I I
thought to myself so the whole economy
eight women make 80% of consumer buying
decisions what are the odds that changes
in my
lifetime do I think women are going to
get less Ed there's no evidence to
suggest it's going the other
way so how do you adapt in a modern
world is the real
question yeah there are four women on
the Supreme Court yep
see pumping out media that is truthful
well if media was the solution why
hasn't 50 years of media turned people
more
conservative it seems like it actually
produced the opposite effect if media
was the
solution
is this is this
crazy and everyone's getting kind of
fatter you know there's more sex workers
I'm demonetized guys but I did get I'm
gonna look I did get great content thank
you James for the Super Chat on venmo
appreciate you
um I is this really going any
where I don't think so so how do you
adapt because the world's going like
even okay I was thinking about this and
this is brainstorming men are very
solution oriented so maybe you know you
know you could
homeschool but even if you homeschool
your kids like you have kids you do the
Trad thing you're still in a society
that isn't Trad there's no proof for
evidence that if you have
children they're going to be traditional
and conservative and have all these
grandkids
and and really I I don't think you're
meant to impose your will on adults you
know I think you should encourage you
Gotta Give Kids the tools to make
decisions and they either make them or
they don't someone asked where's the
shopping spree you know guys I'm sorry I
really wanted to do it but I had to go
back on Pierce Morgan a day early um
I did I really wanted to do it with sneo
I thought it would have been really
funny but I just I couldn't do it I felt
I felt a little
bad so I wanted
um to pull something up hold
on you know do I think it's likely that
we're gonna have a Christian theocracy
and I'm not going to lie you know I mean
people
sound really good when they talk about
this even Nick like last year like he
sounds really good he sounds really
inspiring when I listen to him talk he's
super
inspiring but and maybe I maybe I'm just
a Debbie Downer I don't know
but you know the solution is more
truthful
media I mean I maybe but I I wouldn't I
don't think that is the the solution
let's say we wanted to repeal the
men's rights activists have been working
to just get more fair laws for
men for 50 years what what makes you
think you can switch
it um that's why you move the good to
the good communities or build your own
good communities through online
Communications now I don't necessarily
think that's false but I still think
women have a nature and when you give
freedom to women women will always
always always go for the top 20% of men
so as a guy you can either decide if you
want to be the top 20% of men and maybe
pick one to settle down with be the
relationship guy that tends to get with
the women after they've been with the
top 20% of men or be or walk away and
just be part of the sexist
men and as women um we really can if we
want to and by the way guys I think this
is biology I I don't think this is a
choice in a
way you know women have the choice to
either go for a top 20% guy that you
actually like but you'll probably have
to deal with him
cheating and why do I think that because
do you know how different the world is
going to be in 10 20 years half of women
guys are going to be single and
childless half 50% of
women it is going to be competitive if
you get married to a top 20% guy you
will have no leverage none none none
none then the next option is
to marry a guy you don't really like
that much and I see Christian women do
this all the time oh my gosh that's like
the standard in the Christian church and
they'll be like Pearl what churches do
you go to I've been to churches
all over the freaking
world um know and guys and they'll say
you don't have to accept that it doesn't
always
happen I I go with what I think is more
likely than not likely it's not about my
morals none of this is about what I
think is right I look for patterns and
Trends and I I see how things will play
out so okay you build these Trad
Christian communities but they're still
social media women are still women
they're still going to go for the top
20% of men that means I mean a bunch of
chicks are gonna cheat like the same the
same thing is gonna
happen Indian culture no I
really I've seen very similar stuff I
know the divorce rate's lower but it's
not and I see everybody coping everyone
all the tradcons are saying no we're
going to fight this it's going to go a
different
way and you know I I think maybe one
solution could be tax incentives for
kids with married
parents but I still see women being
women and women will push polygamy women
are going to push it because women would
rather share a top guy than be with a
guy that they don't
like
I don't make the
rules and
then
so when I first got into this red pill
stuff I thought to myself no that's not
true I don't want to like I would rather
have a guy to myself and that's what I
said but then I would watch what I
did and you know there's there's been
times where I've been with a guy and he
was wasn't
faithful I didn't
leave even me because women are
women women are
women
so yeah so
how to adapt in the modern world now now
I will say there is another side of this
there is another side luckily most
people are fat and
lazy
yes yes yes yes a lot of people are fat
and lazy and just don't work
hard and because of this there is more
opportunity
for women and men to get in the top
20% you know as women body positivity it
just means less competition for us all
these women getting tattoos it means
less competition for us all these women
dying their hair blue chopping it off
what does that mean for us less
competition as a woman you can get a guy
like two points out of your league I
would say
just by not having tattoos not being fat
not having
debt and not being a complete
men on the other hand I will say
life is much harder as a
man
but most men are overweight
too you
know most you know I I think the average
salary is 35 40,000 a year now it really
isn't fair because women are stealing
men's money and I do believe that it's
much harder as a guy
but there are ways to make money online
that we've never had in all of history
you used to have to like work on a
farm
um you know there there's there's light
at the end of the tunnel for people that
want
it um and what I realized is that most
of media is just it's like you know like
when I started I thought we were all
looking for a solution and the
truth but the problem is the
conservatives can't handle how women
are and that's why they're
losing because none of them understand
female
nature my opinion
anyways so
Pearl keep up the great work some of
send some of them loyal fans to my
channel no I will not we are in
Desperate Times
sorry sorry this is I can't send anybody
also I wanted to shout out um Allan gave
me $100 this week so I appreciate
it so anyways
I know these have just been random rants
that I think of and to tie it all back
into my dad my dad
um thinks like this like he thinks in
terms of like practical advice and
solutions and I
think yeah I I think that a lot of media
is just people arguing without you know
and it's fun don't get me wrong I love
dunking on people it's amazing
but you
know what is what is the solution for
most
people I don't know so let me know what
you think in the
comments
um make sure you like the video and
subscribe you know I I'm gonna I'm gonna
do a bet I just want to Durant today I
was just feeling it guys um feel free to
send you know a Super
Chat
like the video
subscribe and I'm gonna I'm gonna talk
to you guys next
time um okay goodbye